[Music] foreign
So I'm really really excited about this next
sequence of lectures on the numerical integrationof ordinary differential equations
because this iswhere we take a lot of what we have learned so farabout how to solve systems of ordinary differentialequations
and we move this into much morereal world settings.
So we've talked about howto solve linear coupled systems
of first orderequations "dx/dt = Ax"
and really these are valid near linearizations near the fixedpoints or equilibrium of general nonlinear systems
but we haven't talked much about how to handlea generic non-linear system of equations "dx/dt = f(x)" where f is a non-linear function
We know that linear systems benefit fromthe fact that linear superposition holds so youcan break this into simpler sub-problems
like you can diagonalize "A" and solveeach of those decoupled problems, and then addthose up and and get a solution.
There aren'tgeneric solutions techniques like thatfor "dx/dt = f(x)" for a non-linear functionf.
And in those cases we often resort to numericalintegration.
So most of the systems we care about
like integrating... predicting the future
of a weather system or an epidemiological system
or a fluid flow system or even a very complicated
mechanical system... typically we can't
... we can't solve them using these linear
techniques and we have to resort to numericalintegration.
So that's what I'm going to show
you in this sequence.
I'm going to walk you through kind of in this lecture the overview
and then we're going to dive into some topics
so I'm going to talk a little bit more
about what I mean by this differential
equation x dot equals f of x here x is typically
a vector of the state of my system it's a vector
representing the state of my
system representing the state
of my system it's often called a state Vector
that's what it's called and f f of x f is a
function of X is generically some non-linear
function it may be a non-linear function it may
be a non-linear function a non-linear function and
it might even vary in time so I've written x dot
equals f of x where f is kind of a constant it's
just a function of X that doesn't change in time
but this function could actually be evolving and
changing in time so that would be an autonomous or
a non-autonomous system would be whether or not
this does or does not depend on time so we'll
talk about both of those actually and one of the
examples I like to give of this is let's say that
I have the fluid flow like in the Gulf of Mexico
something like that so let's say I have you know
this is Florida this is the Gulf of Mexico I'm
from you know somewhere in Texas over over here
and essentially what we have is some
some fluid velocity field sometimes
we call this a vector field so we
have some you know Vector field I'm
just going to draw kind of arrows
and making this up you know maybe
there is some area of big circulation right that's
uh not always a good thing when that happens
um okay so I've got some big Vector field
for the fluid flow in the Gulf of Mexico
and let's say I am lost at sea so I'm like a
little you know I'm on a life raft or something
and I am at this initial condition uh X at time
zero so I not only have this differential equation
I also have some initial condition exit time zero
equals x naught and what I might be interested in
this system is how to so so first off this Vector
field would be f of x it literally says at every
point in Space X what is the vector the fluid
velocity field that is changing my position in
time so I assume that my particle kind of
advects or flows along with this you know
fluid velocity field and at every point in space
here at every point x this is my function f of x
okay is this kind of vector field velocity field
here and you'll notice that in this example this
two-dimensional fluid flow my function f has two
components it has the kind of velocity direction
in the X component and the velocity component
in the y in the y direction so here you know f
of a point x would have you know some uh kind of
x velocity and some y velocity component okay f of
x would have some x velocity and some y velocity
component I'm also going to say that this is not
just some function of X but it's also a function
of time so realistically I actually should
um you know generically add in this um possibility
that my function my right hand side ordinary
differential equation can be changing or evolving
in time so of course you know this flow velocity
is constantly evolving in the in the Gulf of
Mexico it's constantly changing in time uh
because you know the ocean is churning and wind
is blowing the surface and changing things so
this is actually changing in time and these pink
arrows are actually going to be moving in timethemselves
What I really am interested in
is if I have some initial condition 'x_0'
how can I predict where that trajectory is going to
go in future times? So can I actually
that's what I mean by numerical integration of ODEs, ofan ordinary differential equation, is can I tell
where this trajectory is going to go in the future
by stepping It forward in these discrete
discrete 'delta t' advances in time. So if
I know 'x_0' can I predict what it'll be
one time step in the future? Can I predict
what x at time one will be? can I predict what x
at time two and x at time three and so on and soforth... can I predict a trajectory? So that's what
we call a trajectory I'm just going to write this
down so we say a trajectory
is a path -- and I'm really going to say it's somepath 'x(t)' -- so it's some
path 'x(t)' -- so this is x(t) -- but numerically
when I do this on a computer when I solve this
on a computer what that is actually going to be
often is discretized at discrete points in time.
So I'm going to approximate this continuous
path with these discrete points x_0
x_1, x_2, ... all the
way up to x_n
and sometimes if I drop my under bar here you know these are still vectors
of states so please don't be confused if I forget
an underbar and so what I mean by a trajectory is
typically you know I have some X naught and that's
going to be going to some X1 and that's going to
be going to some X2 dot dot dot all the way to
some X n so that's what I mean by a trajectory
is a kind of either continuous or discrete path
of points in time where x k is equal to X at
some kth time instance and oftentimes I'm going
to say that these are sampled at a at a constant
discrete delta T So TK my kth time instant would
actually be K delta T time steps okay you don't
have to take constant time steps but usually in
our numerical integration schemes we're going
to be taking these constant time steps we'll
we'll cook up an algorithm that will step the
system forward that will approximate this true
trajectory at these discrete time instances
for this differential equation and again I'm
I'm going to reiterate the reason we need to resort tonumerical integration
of these non-linear ordinarydifferential equations
like finding a trajectory evolving in the Gulf of Mexico
is because
there is a fundamental limit to what we can do
with analytical techniques, with linear techniques,
with pencil and paper techniques.  So in really
really big problems, or in really complicated
problems, these linear techniques are
only valid near fixed points, in neighborhoods
of fixed points, typically. And it might be really
hard to find these fixed points or hard to analyze
these for very high-dimensional systems. And
so we have to resort to numerical integration for
most real world problems of interest.
So in this example I might want to
predict, if I'm in some life raft in the Gulf of
Mexico, someone might want to predict based on my
last location where am I going to be a day from
now, or two days from now, or something like that.
You might also predict where was I last seen...
you might actually integrate this backward in time
and figure out: okay, well this is my last location...
you can integrate these trajectories backwards in
times, sometimes, and you might do that to figure
out where you came from... where a
particle or a trajectory came from. Integrating particles in the Gulf of Mexico is
also useful if there is a big oil spill and you
want to know where this blob of oil is going to
go five days from now, if you want to do
a cleanup.
And so that begs the next question and that's something I'm going to talk about in thisso so in this series what I'm going to do I'm just
going to write some of these things out here so
we are going to derive numerical schemes numerical
schemes uh to construct these trajectories to
approximate these trajectories to approximate
to approximate uh kind of X at some next time
point x k plus one equals some function of x k so
if I know my position at time step now I want to
be able to predict my position at time Step at the
next time step so let's say this is x k and this
is X K plus one I want to be able to build some
numerical scheme some big F that approximates a
one delta T time step forward so then I can build
this trajectory starting from my initial condition
by just running it through my numerical scheme
and so some of the numerical schemes we're going
to cook up are going to be things like the forward
and backward Euler forward Euler and backward
Euler I might even derive one of these today
in this lecture backward Euler we're going to
derive things like the Runge-Kutta schemes these
are really really powerful so Runge-Kutta I've
heard this pronounced uh Runge-Kutta I call it
Runge-Kutta and so there's you know second order
and fourth order and so I'm going to talk about
these Runge-Kutta schemes which are kind of the
built-in integrators in Python and Matlab very
very good all-purpose numerical integrators quite
accurate and then I'm also going to talk about
Advanced schemes like variational and symplectic
integrators advanced advanced integrators
these numerical Miracle schemes are called
integrators because we are kind of integrating
you know this D X DT we're integrating it in time
to time Step It Forward so then I'll talk about
Advanced integrators for chaotic systems for
chaos for let's just say for chaos for chaotic
systems because for chaotic systems you need
a little bit more specialized Machinery okay
so that's one thing we're going to do is we're
actually going to derive these different schemes
kind of starting with the very very simplest then
getting to kind of the all-purpose integrators and
then getting into some Advanced integrators if
you really really need Advanced capabilities for
integrating these trajectories for these schemes
we're going to talk about specific properties
like error properties we're going to look at
the error and we're going to look at stability
stability and specifically I'm mostly going to
look at the error and stability properties of
these simple Euler and Runge-Kutta schemes
but that's going to build our intuition for
more generalized integrators that you might come
into contact with later in your in your research
or in your work so for all of these schemes we
need to be concerned with how accurate is this
scheme if I assume that I have a good estimate
of f how accurate you know what is the error for
each of these schemes and what is the stability
will these actually you know are these going to
Faithfully reproduce my my trajectory or is my
forward Euler sometimes going to diverge if I
use too big of a Time step that definitely
happens and I'm going to tell you why that
happens okay so these are you know probably going
to be four or five or six lectures building on
on this kind of overview lecture maybe I'll
have a whole series you know that I'll add
to occasionally because I actually do a lot
of work in this numerical integration world
um good other things that we care
about that I want to tell you about is
I like this oil spill example because I think it's
pretty intuitive to think about... or maybe
... or maybe my lifeboat example.   Maybe I get
lost at sea and there's some report that I was
missing sometime around 3 P.M on Saturday
on this beach... some beach here... and so based on
that information, there is some uncertainty in my
initial condition and my initial time. And so if
I have a little bit of an uncertainty here, so I
don't know exactly what my initial condition is,
but I have some little Gaussian of
uncertainty or a little uniform uncertainty
how does that propagate and grow? How does
that uncertainty grow as I go forward in
time with these different integration schemes?
Or if I integrate my dynamics, even
if I integrated this perfectly, how does this
uncertainty propagate forward in time? That's
a super important question in engineering and
scientific applications. I want to know how my
uncertainty relates to things like my time step to
the dynamics themselves, whether they're chaotic or
not chaotic. I want to know for what
parameter values does this uncertainty grow
a lot or a little? Those are very important
questions and they're deeply related to
this concept of chaos, of sensitive dependence on
initial conditions and chaotic systems. You can get
really different trajectories even if their
initial conditions are arbitrarily close together.
So we're going to also talk quite a bit about
chaotic systems and how to integrate and
propagate uncertainty in these systems, which is
a really interesting and really rich area.
What else do I want to tell you about [Music]
um so this function f itself could be the solution
of another differential equation or dynamical
system so the vector field F itself so you know
F maybe some non-linear function we call this a
vector field it's a we call it sometimes a vector
field when we're integrating particles through
it because it's literally at every point in in
X and every point in state space it establishes
a vector telling you how X changes in time at
that point and so it's a vector field a field of
vectors and this may be this may be the solution
to a partial differential equation and so actually
the sequence of lectures in differential equations
and dynamical systems very soon after this I'll
tell you about partial differential equations
so these are ordinary differential equations
because they only have a single independent
variable time but soon I'll tell you about
partial differential equations for how this
function f evolves in time so for example in a
fluid flow f the velocity field or the vector
field of a fluid flow it actually satisfies its
own partial differential equation which would be
something like you know the partial derivative
of f with respect to time equals some other
non-linear function of F and maybe it's spatial
derivatives so the Navy or Stokes equations for
fluid flows can be written kind of like this so
the function f itself might be the solution of
another partial differential equation and so we're
interested in this lecture series on integrating a
particle through this ordinary differential
equation Vector field but that Vector field
itself might be the solution of another bigger
dynamical system like the fluid flow equations
like the Navier-Stokes equations okay so I just
think that's kind of interesting there's kind
of layers and layers of complexity of where
you can where you can zoom into these systems
okay um so we're going to be talking about these
different schemes probably in the next lecture I'm
going to derive forward Euler and backward Euler
and look at their error and stability properties
then I'm going to introduce Runge-Kutta and
we're going to look at you know how to code
those up what are their error and stability
properties how do we actually you know compare
those and their properties to these schemes and
then I'm going to talk about chaotic systems
and how to you know propagate uncertainty and
integrate and when you need advanced integrators
maybe one last thing I'll show you before I kind
of go into the next lecture is I'll just give you
a flavor for how we're going to be building
things like forward Euler and backward Euler
Point already have a pretty good idea um of how
to do this what we're going to do is essentially
we're going to take this differential equation
x dot equals f of x and for now we're going to
drop the function of T and I'm just going
to say it's x dot equals f of x and we're
going to assume that F doesn't change in
time just to make my life easier but all
of this applies to time varying Vector fields
we're going to do is we're going to take our DX
DT and again remember that this is approximately
equal to this finite difference derivative that I
showed you in the last few lectures so um what
I can do is I can say that my derivative is
you know so this is x dot that's approximately
equal let me let me uh yeah so at some time T
at some time T the derivative of x of T at some
time T is going to be X at time t plus delta T
minus X at time T divided by delta T we know that
there's some error associated with this we can
look at the Taylor series of this expression plug
it in and figure out how much error there is so
this is really only approximately equal to this
but we can use this approximation if we have a
small enough delta T and we can set that equal to
f of x at T okay and so based on this expression
I can now solve for x at my next time step in
terms of X at my current time step so I get X
at t plus delta T is approximately equal to again
this is only approximately equal to the right hand
side because this is an approximation of x dot
so X of t plus delta T is approximately equal
I multiply both sides by delta T I add X of T
and I get X of t plus Delta t f of X of T okay
and so this is the simplest possible numerical
integrator to take if I have exit time now I
can step it forward and get X at 1 delta T in the
future so this is my forward Euler scheme this is
forward Euler because Euler developed this and
looked at these properties for forward Euler
what I want here which is to build a trajectory if
I have exit time 0 I can step that forward and get
x one time step in the future at Exit time one
if I have exit time one you know at one delta T
then I have exit delta T and I have f of x
at delta T I can get f of x at 2 delta T and
if I have f of x if I have X at 2 delta T I can
get X at 3 delta T and 4 delta T and I can step
that forward and build this integrator so this
is that big f of x k that I was talking about
over here and so sometimes you're going to see us
write this as you know X at time step K plus 1 1
delta T in the future is equal to my current time
step exit my current time step plus Delta t f of
x at my current time step and the way we would
interpret these subscripts is this means I'm at
time t k or time K delta T and so if I want to
write this out long form I would say this is X
at time X at time t K plus delta T that's
time K plus 1 is TK plus another delta T
equals x at time t k plus
Delta t f of x at time t k
okay so that's how you can kind of go back and
forth between these subscript K's and some time
uh some absolute actual clock time 't_k' okay the
K time that I'm keeping track of and so this is
going to be the name of the game for this whole
lecture series for forward or backward oil or
second order fourth order Runge-Kutta and these
Advanced schemes it's super super simple at the
heart what we're going to do is we're going to
approximate DX DT using some some type of finite
difference derivative scheme and we're going to
to use that we're going to set that equal to f
of x and we're going to build a scheme to predict
x one time step in the future based on X now okay
so that's all coming up I'm going to derive all of
these look at their error and stability and we're
going to start integrating starting with simple
systems we're going to integrate like you know
a mass on a spring with a damper so we'll go back
to our kind of trusty canonical spring Mass damper
we'll integrate a non-linear pendulum with a
large amplitude so it's not going to we're not
just going to use the small angle approximation
anymore so a large amplitude pendulum and then
we're going to move into chaotic systems like
the Lorenz attractor let's see if I can draw
my my Lorenz attractor we'll get into chaotic
systems like the butterfly attractor and like
the double pendulum so the single pendulum is
deterministic and it gives you a Clockwork of
periodic motion but the double pendulum where
I have a single pendulum attached to another
pendulum these are both chaotic systems so we're
going to build these integrators and test them
out on all of these interesting systems that's
all coming up in the next let's say five six
lectures I'm looking forward to it I hope you are
this is going to be kind of the culmination of
what we've talked about in ordinary differential
equations we're going to use our intuition for
the error analysis we're going to use eigenvalues
and eigenvectors to understand stability of these
schemes and then we're going to take this
into the next level of really applying this
to hard real-world fully non-linear systems uh
that's all coming up all right thank you [Music]